not isis not al-qaeda
white supremacists
ah it doesn't have to provide an actual
argument he just throws out imran x
candy style circular reasoning and then
you're just expected to accept it that's
the reason he was in tulsa
okay so meanwhile joe biden was down in
tulsa oklahoma he was paying homage
to the 100-year commemoration of the
tulsa massacre which we talked about
yesterday and i think in order to
understand
joe biden when it comes to race you have
to understand that the entire democratic
party right now
has decided to central centralized
they've decided to center all their
attention around a new definition of
racism
their definition of racism is anything
they don't like now that's been their
definition for a while but their new
theory is that all the institutions of
american life
are shot through with racism and they
never have to define racism see you and
i could define racism pretty easily
because we speak the language of english
racism means that you believe in the
superiority or inferiority of people
based specifically on their race that is
the definition of racism
but the left doesn't believe in that
definition because if that's the
definition then racism
has been alleviated largely over the
course of american history
right particularly over the last 60
years most americans understand that to
believe such things
is considered evil in our society right
to be an actual honest god racist who
believes in the inferiority of somebody
based on race
is something that is not even considered
remotely within the bounds
of the rational in modern society and in
modern discourse so what did the left
have to do
instead they had to say well the
institutions of america are shot through
with racism
and we don't actually have to define
that we're just going to say it
and then if you don't understand what
we're talking about we're just going to
say it again so the great
sort of prevaricator about this sort of
stuff and popularizer of this sort of
nonsense is ibrahim x kennedy so ever
max kennedy is a professor at boston
university which is insane and
demonstrates the uselessness of higher
education
he's also the head of what is called the
center for anti-racism research which
today has provided
zero research so far as i'm aware but
has taken in literally tens of millions
of dollars from major institutions
including 10 million dollars from jack
dorsey of twitter
just last year for brilliance like this
so here was ever max kennedy this is i
believe a couple of years ago at the
aspen ideas festival he was asked
explicitly
how do you define racism and here is
ibrahmax kennedy attempting to define
racism
this is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard but this is the basis for race
ideology on the left today
so racism i would define it as a
collection
of racist policies that lead to racial
inequity
that are substantiated by racist ideas
and anti-racism
is a pretty simple using the same terms
anti-racism is a collection of
anti-racist policies leading to
racial anybody i want to guess equity
that are substantiated by anti-racist
ideas okay this is
the fact my favorite part of this is
where he he kind of arches his eyebrows
because he said something quite profound
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard in my life the reason it's the
dumbest thing i've ever heard in my life
is if somebody asks you to define a term
and then you use the term in the
definition you have not defined the term
i'm holding a pen right here
if you said define a pen and i said a
pen is a pen
you'd be like that that added no new
information i have no idea what you're
talking about
if i said to you define racism and you
said racism is a thing that is racist
because it is motivated by racism you'd
be like i don't know what you're talking
about because that didn't add any new
information ever max kenny says this
says this crap with a straight face and
everybody just goes oh
ooh ah okay but this provides the basis
for democrats to say
that any inequality of outcome is
representative
of racism in the system and this has
been imbibed at the deepest level
by the democratic party so that was the
purpose of joe biden going to tulsa it
wasn't just to provide
some sort of commemoration for an evil
uh of an evil event in american life it
was to say that that evil event is
indicative
of what america was and remains with
regard to black americans
so joe biden goes down to tulsa oklahoma
first he has a fight with his
teleprompter
i mean this is just requisite just as
like an opening as an opening move
as an opening gambit in every one of his
rallies he actually brings out the
teleprompter and then he physically
spars with it so here is
joe biden versus the teleprompter as
always a belief
enforced by law by badge
by hood and by noose that speaks
to that lit the fuse
it lit it by the spark that it provided
a fuse a fury
was an innocent interaction that turned
into an
ins terrible terrible headline
allegation
yeah man teleprompter puts joe down for
the count as always
but the real purpose here is to conflate
two ideas
idea number one is that we should come
to grips with america's history of
racism
obviously true we should pay attention
to things like the tulsa massacre
because that is a part of american
history that was neglected in education
for a very long time
my guess is that only in the last few
years have most americans even been made
aware
of the tulsa massacre as opposed to like
the civil war or as opposed to world war
one or world war
ii but the reality is that that is a
fairly
and that's good i'm glad more people are
aware of the tulsa massacre now
that that is a very good thing but the
idea is that if you
are opposed to the racialized agenda of
the biden administration if you say
things have kind of changed between 1921
and 2021 which they most indubitably
have
then this means that you want to deny
history so here was joe biden
doing exactly performing exactly this
sort of conflation here was yesterday
saying that america is great because
we're coming to terms now with our dark
side
we should know the good
the bad everything that's what great
nations do they come to terms
with their dark sides and we're a great
nation
alrighty so um we're coming to terms
with our dark side but what he means by
that is that we are going to
fundamentally shift the way
that institutions are run in the united
states in a racist fashion
so biden says americans think that if i
hold you down i lift myself up this is a
pretty wild statement
for too long we've allowed a narrowed
cramped
view of the promise of this nation to
fester
the view that america is a zero-sum game
where there's only one winner if you
succeed
i fail if you get ahead
i'm fall behind if you get a job
i lose mine and maybe worst of all
if i hold you down i lift myself
up okay how many americans believe that
right now like truly how many americans
believe that
how many americans are like he's saying
that americans today are malevolent
right too many americans believe that i
have to hold you down in order to lift
myself up so americans are really really
bad people like today
not in 1921 today americans are terrible
not only that joe biden said that white
supremacy is the greatest threat in
america today it is the greatest threat
in america today
now here's the thing white supremacists
horrible people believe
horrible things no one has been more
critical of white supremacists than i
have
i've been personally targeted by white
supremacists the fbi arrested a white
supremacist a couple of years ago trying
to kill me and my family
okay so white supremacist and i not
friends
also he conflates white supremacy with
pretty much everything he doesn't like
and this is part of the danger how many
headlines have you seen in the media
recently saying things
like healthcare disparities are a result
of white supremacy
right how many times have you seen
members of this administration
talk about how inequal
unequal outcomes in the justice system
are the result of white supremacy as
opposed to you know individual action by
people of different races
okay so here is joe biden laying it out
there here we go
as i said in my address the joint
session of congress according to the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most
lethal threat to the homeland today not
isis not al qaeda white
supremacists that's not me
that's the intelligence community under
both trump
and under my administration okay so
first of all if he just wants to say
that that white supremacist terrorism
happens and is threatening
that's okay i have no problem with that
but if the argument is that the most
lethal threat to americans today
is white supremacist to terrorists that
is not true by any statistical measure
of which i am aware
the most lethal threat to americans
today like overall
or the most lethal threat to america
today that's overall all of this is
driven by an agenda
right the agenda is that joe biden wants
to radically remake america's
institutions he doesn't have to provide
data he doesn't have to provide natural
argument
he just throws out imran x candy style
circular reasoning and then you're just
expected to accept it
that's the reason he was in tulsa it was
not just to commemorate it was obviously
to provide the predicate for shifting
america's institutions
and our notions of individual rights
versus the government
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content